authorities in Belgium are investigating
an orphanage for abducting and
trafficking children from the Democratic
Republic of Congo the children are said
to have been taken to Belgium and
adopted by families who were told that
they were orphans now it emerges that
the parents of those children one of
them you see behind me are alive and
never gave up their children two Belgian
journalists uncovered the scandal in the
village of Gilman at eight hundred
kilometers north of the capital Kinshasa
they found the biological parents of
some of the children my guest today is
one of the two journalists that
uncovered the scandal Kurt virtualize
joins me now from our studio in the
Belgian capital Brussels welcome to to
DW Africa Kurt how were these children
taken from their parents in the
Democratic Republic of Congo and how did
they then land up in Belgium
well we've discovered that were at least
two ways of taking these kids first you
had some kind of holidays and on a
holiday that the holiday that they kind
of fixed for the for the kids going from
gaming at the north of Congo to Kinshasa
that was one way parents were eager to
send their kids on this holiday because
it was one time in one one chance in
lifetime that was one thing and second
way of getting these kids in the
orphanage was plain kidnapping going on
the road with a bicycle or with with a
motorbike I'm sorry and kidnapping the
kids that the orphanage needed right so
the families that you you visited in the
Democratic Republic of Congo excuse me
these people have for the last three
years if I'm not mistaken been under the
impression that their children had died
and so you pitched up and told them that
their children were alive I mean just
tell us about that moment when you broke
this news to them and what have they
been going through over the last few
years well they are at the at the moment
we've we found these people they were
absolutely unaware of
happen to their kids if there were dead
or alive where they were they had no ID
the kids were taken and they had no idea
where they were so it was our first
contact we tried to to talk to the
parents the biological parents they gave
us lots of details about the kids about
how they lived and and so on and at the
end we could provide them with pictures
of of their kids pictures taken years
after or at least one year after the the
kidnapping so we could prove that they
were still alive we could tell them also
that they were in good shape that they
were in Belgium that they were seen in
South and that at the end all of the
parents they gave us a video message to
provide to the kids and the adoptive
families and what well like it's it's
needs no explanation that of course in
all of the village everybody was very
happy to know to have news about the
kids and that of course that they were
not dead and that they that they were
still alive yes right could just tell us
about how you and your colleague came to
uncovering the story well I can't go
into all details but I had some contacts
and they pointed out this story to me
and I've worked for a few months of the
radar and try to locate at least the
organization that provided the the
transportation for them for the the
summer holiday that the kids were going
to and it took me some well some time a
few months to get in touch with them and
to gain confidence and finally meet them
and that's the way I got I got to
Kinshasa and later on to gaming up to
the north of Congo and it was through
this well through this way that I I
finally met the parents okay so there
are legal proceedings in in Brussels now
as we have said in a Belgian court
who is on trial and what exactly is is
going to happen now what are we gonna
see coming out of these legal
proceedings well as far as I know right
now the federal prosecutor is trying to
close down the the affair the the file
and they have found so far at evidence
for at least five of these kidnappings
they have DNA matches with the the
parents that we found in in Congo and
the kids that are in Belgium they as far
as I know now they are trying to close
down the investigation and go to trial
with at least one of the responsibles a
woman that's that lives in Belgium a
woman that has the Belgian and Congolese
nationality and that was travelling
around from Belgium to Congo and back
with about two to two to arrange all
these adoptions at least she will be on
trial or that that is the expectation
and probably they will also find some
other people in her well close by that
might have given her help
that's the Legion the legal thing the
other thing is of course the what will
happen to the children they Belgium now
for for a few years so that's another
procedure that that's ongoing all right
so it's too soon to say if the if the
children will be returned to the
Democratic Republic of Congo to their
parents yes it's it's too soon to say
and at this moment it's it's very
difficult of course you have the
biological parents in Congo that really
want their children back and you have on
the other side the adoptive parents in
Belgium that have raised these kids not
being aware of the fact that they were
abducted so it's it's a tricky situation
and there in the end there will be no
winner of course this will be hard for
for everybody yes
third fistula is thank you